[Musique]
bonsoir thème qui nous sommes ravis de
nous retrouver aujourd'hui
nous étions bien loin nous a t-on
joie de rentrer deux pays ouattara
avez-vous bien joué avez-vous bien
chanté avez vous jeté gentil et ça je
crois que quelques enfants ont été
cuites au méchant au bâton mais nous
étions en voyage
puisque oddo entrons chez nous parlions
au petit filet opi d'arçons
je fondais j'habite mon petit je relis
toi de nous tuer trop gentil
essayons nous verrons oui mais à
condition qu'ils aient une conduite
parfaite
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous allons aussi à
tue tête
bonsoir
enfin on est bien content aujourd'hui et
pour galons tas
hop on va me dire tous les soirs
dire bonne nuit cher peu bizarre
bal de nuit c'est petit ça brille
aux patrons je descend vite voir nicolas
et pimprenelle dealer bonjour d'un
appart nord semi oui je suis certain
qu'ils ont été sages pendant notre
absence mais petit cadeau
mon échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
tu ne crois pas qu'il viendra ce soir
pimprenelle et nicolas
j'aimerais tellement jouer avec lui
[Musique]
regard
scène l'ancien ses filles mais oui c'est
moi on soit en les petits
qu'est ce que tu nous as lu nos geôliers
toile argentée pour pape rhône elle
[Musique]
est pour nicolas hulot chromées tout
temps
[Musique]
s'était trouvé dans le ciel je les ai
attrapé au vol des fins
mais dites moi avez vous été sage
oui c'est bien mais pas preneur
moi je suis toujours ça
[Rires]
s'active à certains moments du miel diop
à longues robes aux romains à campagne
nous lis tu vas qui est toujours si ça
j'en donnerai une cuillère au marchand
de sable
si les sages
lyon aussi
connu de nos gentils tu viendrais du oui
en dormez-vous vite les petits
là c'est un leurre
à
tomates et man ouest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma parole tu as été gâtés ne mange pas
toutes au miel d'une seule fois ou
aux propos pas trop et vous ça mais ça
dépend
pas toujours nounours mais bien puisque
vous n'êtes pas toujours traçage je n'ai
pas besoin de vous donner de miel
alors en route gros coquin
bonnut les enfants allez vite vous
coucher le fun ii pour eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]